We're convinced that kids don't need our help,
that they "know everything" about technology.
When I was a kid,
at one point, my parents started letting me walk to school alone.
After years of taking me by the hand and walking me to school,
one day they sat me down,
gave me the house keys
and said, "Be very careful with these; don't give them to anyone,
take the route we showed you, be at home at the time we said,
cross at the corner, and look both ways before you cross,
and no matter what, don't talk to strangers."
I knew everything about walking,
and yet, there was a responsible adult there taking care of me.
Knowing how to do something is one thing,
knowing how to take care of yourself is another.
Imagine this situation:
I'm 10 or 11 years old, I wake up in the morning,
my parents toss me the keys and say,
"Seba, now you can walk to school alone."
And when I come back late,
they say, "No, you need to be home at the time we said."
And two weeks later,
when it comes up, they say, "You know what?
You have to cross at the corner, and look both ways before crossing."
And two years later, they say,
"And also, don't talk to strangers."
It sounds absurd, right?
We have the same absurd behavior in relation to technology.
We give kids total access
and we see if one day, sooner or later,
they learn how to take care of themselves.
Knowing how to do something is one thing,
knowing how to take care of yourself is another.
Along those same lines, when we talk to parents,
they often say they don't care about technology and social networks.
I always rejoin that by asking if they care about their kids.
As adults, being interested or not in technology
is the same as being interested or not in our kids.
The internet is part of their lives.
Technology forces us to rethink the relationship between adults and kids.
Education was always based on two main concepts:
experience and knowledge.
How do we teach our kids to be safe online when we don't have either?
Nowadays, we adults have to guide our children
through what is often for us unfamiliar territory --
territory much more inviting for them.
It's impossible to find an answer
without doing new things -- things that make us uncomfortable,
things we're not used to.
A lot of you may think it's easy for me,
because I'm relatively young.
And it used to be that way.
Used to.
Until last year,
when I felt the weight of my age on my shoulders
the first time I opened Snapchat.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
I didn't understand a thing!
I found it unnecessary,
useless, hard to understand;
it looked like a camera!
It didn't have menu options!
It was the first time I felt the gap
that sometimes exists between kids and adults.
But it was also an opportunity to do the right thing,
to leave my comfort zone, to force myself.
I never thought I'd ever use Snapchat,
but then I asked my teenage cousin to show me how to use it.
I also asked why she used it.
What was fun about it?
We had a really nice talk.
She showed me her Snapchat, she told me things,
we got closer, we laughed.
Today, I use it.
(Laughter)
I don't know if I do it right,
but the most important thing is that I know it and I understand it.
The key was to overcome the initial shock
and do something new.
Something new.
Today, we have the chance to create new conversations.
What's the last app you downloaded?
Which social network do you use to contact your friends?
What kind of information do you share?
Have you ever been approached by strangers?
Could we have these conversations between kids and adults?
We have to force ourselves to do it. All of us.
Today, lots of kids are listening to us.
Sometimes when we go to schools to give our talks,
or through social networks,
kids ask or tell us things
they haven't told their parents or their teachers.
They tell us -- they don't even know us.
Those kids need to know
what the risks of being online are,
how to take care of themselves,
but also that, fundamentally, as with almost everything else,
kids can learn this from any adult.
Online safety needs to be a conversation topic
in every house and every classroom in the country.
We did a survey this year that showed that 15 percent of schools said
they knew of cases of grooming in their school.
And this number is growing.
Technology changed every aspect of our life,
including the risks we face
and how we take care of ourselves.
Grooming shows us this in the most painful way:
by involving our kids.
Are we going to do something to avoid this?
The solution starts with something as easy as:
talking about it.
Thank you.
(Applause)